[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAG-INGE AAS: Two years
ago, we had a problem.
SVEIN WILLASSEN: We
were a small team
of developers based in Norway.
DAG-INGE AAS: And
we wanted to be
able to communicate
with friends and family
in other parts of the world.
SVEIN WILLASSEN:
But getting everyone
to install the same
video chat application
was just too painful.
DAG-INGE AAS: So we decided
to build our own solution.
With three students
in just two weeks,
we made the Appear In web
app-- messaging and video
chat, no plug-ins, no
installation required.
SVEIN WILLASSEN: We used WebRTC,
a set of open source APIs
for real time communications.
DAG-INGE AAS: Only one problem,
as our web app got popular,
we soon discovered
that WebRTC was not
supported across all browsers.
Some of our friends
wanted native apps
for their phones and tablets.
So after all that
wonderful webbiness,
we realized that
in the real world
we'd have to build native apps.
But it turned out
that wasn't a problem.
WebRTC has great support for
native iOS and Android apps.
I'm Dag-Inge.
SVEIN WILLASSEN: And I'm Svein.
If you're a web developer
like me, hold onto your hat.
By the end of this
video, you'll have
resources to get started with
WebRTC on iOS and Android.
DAG-INGE AAS: As we'll show you,
the APIs for iOS and Android
parallel those for the web.
WebRTC is an open standard
and secure peer-to-peer
communication of
audio, video or data.
In the past, a lot of
real time communication
ran by a centralized service.
That was inefficient
and expensive.
WebRTC enables apps to
communicate directly
from device-to-device,
peer-to-peer without going
via a third party server.
SVEIN WILLASSEN: This means
communication with WebRTC
comes at very little cost
to you as a developer.
Since WebRTC is built on
peer-to-peer communication,
most of the data cost
is left to the network.
DAG-INGE AAS: So WebRTC
works peer-to-peer.
But they can't simply
shout into the internet,
I want to exchange streaming
data with my friend's computer.
WebRTC apps need to
negotiate a connection.
In order to set up
a call, WebRTC apps
first need to exchange
connectivity and media
metadata, stuff like network
addresses and audio and video
capabilities.
This process is
called signaling.
SVEIN WILLASSEN:
For signaling, you
can use any two-way
messaging system.
We chose WebSocket
with Socket.IO.
Once a call is set up, media
flows directly between peers.
DAG-INGE AAS: Having built
a signaling mechanism,
the next step in your
WebRTC app is get video
from the camera and audio
from the microphone.
SVEIN WILLASSEN:
On the web, we used
to the navigator.getUserMedia
method to access streams
from the camera and microphone.
DAG-INGE AAS: The
equivalent on Android
is VideoCapturer to fetch
audio and video streams
and VideoRenderer
to display video.
VideoCapturer is a neat
wrap around a camera
API allowing WebRTC to
create the mediastream.
On iOS, RTCVideoCapturer
and RTCVideoRenderer
do the same job.
SVEIN WILLASSEN: Once we get
media streams from the camera
and mic, we need to set up a
network connection to transmit
the streams to other users.
To do this on the web, we
have RTCPeerConnection,
the JavaScript API for audio
and video communication.
This is the core of WebRTC.
The peer connection API does
a lot signal processing,
codec handling, peer-to-peer
communication, security,
bandwidth management, and so on.
DAG-INGE AAS: On Android,
the equivalent API
is PeerConnection and on
iOS it's RTCPeerConnection.
WebRTC opens up
communications to all of us,
open technology, free for
developers, free for end users.
SVEIN WILLASSEN: WebRTC enabled
us with a team of only eight
to build a competitor
for mainstream video chat
application.
DAG-INGE AAS: But WebRTC
enables a lot more
than just video chats.
Along with high performance
audio and video,
WebRTC's peer-to-peer
architecture
enables fast file sharing
and data communication.
Peer-to-peer means less network
ops resulting in lower latency.
We've seen WebRTC apps for music
collaboration, file sharing,
health services,
robots and even gaming.
To learn more, check out the
resources at g.co/webrtc.
You'll find detailed guides,
sample code, demos for Android
and iOS WebRTC developments.
BOTH: Goodbye.
NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]